sie hat ganz doll wein diana amft spielt
die hauptrolle im kinofilm frisch
gepresst und steht in frage motto rede
und antwort und dort ist noch mehr
persönliches zu erfahren
jetzt erst interessant
das ist irgendwie passt das ist jetzt
irgendwie grün sind nette fragen und
ronan diese sind dann nur zwei grüne
müssen drei grüne und drei rote ok
kannst selbst wählen meint ob ich feige
bin oder nicht ich finde das ja bin sehr
gespannt ob die feige bist oder nicht
ich sagt er gleich was meine
einschätzung ist wenn alle roten
natürlich ja wie viel darf ich denn du
darfst alle nehmen oder keine oder eine
keine wäre doch dann wird es keine
dämlichen anna lena ja ich fand anfang
war es sehr gut mache ich doch mal was
ihr euch die bösen fragen sie ihren
abdecken also abdrehen einfach abdrehen
genau toll das ist ja hier wie
kindergeburtstag spielen so ein bisschen
man endlich wieder was spielen dürfen
hat dein erfolg mit seiner haarfarbe zu
tun weiß ich nicht ich kann sich
beantworten
ja das stimmt schwierige frage für grund
ihn wirklich schwierig ja jetzt die
länge sie ist nicht zu beantworten und
vielleicht ja ja ja ich bin blond und
hatte das ist schwer zu beantworten aber
ja also ich sag mal so ja der hat also
meine haarfarbe hat für den erfolg der
blonden rollen hat sie glaube ich
wesentlich mitgespielt
okay gut da hab ich plante spielten
nicht verstehen aber meist sohn hat
blonde ist auch oder ist im business
blond er beliebter oder ist das
vollkommen egal ich kenne so wunderbare
schauspieler und schauspielerin mit
dunklen haaren wie aber werden weniger
beschäftigt als blonde das wäre dann die
frage dass sie wundervoll sind wurde
erstmal auf
aber irgendwann wenn ich mal irgendwie
trennte kann ich mich einmal damit
beschäftigen so eine statistik
aufzustellen würdest du das machen ja
angefangen bei den dreißigerjahren okay
gut wunderbar ja gut los
sie haben hier die sendung das ergebnis
seiner crew
okay es ist umgekehrt verstehe versteht
er verstehe die roten sind die lieben
fragen wieso wieso sonst steht in drei
aber ist es immer so schwierig dies
mache weil ich selbst zu sein und laser
vorne mit ihr wissen worum es geht
was macht dich so einzigartig was macht
mich so einzigartig weil der mutter zu
sagen bei schauspielern ist es ja eine
voraussetzung dass sie einzigartig sind
ja sie müssen einzigartig soll ich da
was verraten
ich bin ja der meinung dass jeder jeder
jeder einzelne mensch von uns
einzigartig ist okay im positiven wie im
negativen bei dem muss ist ja irgendwie
positiven liegen du kennst meine anderen
staaten nötig nein
ja also das ist also einzigartig finde
ich ist erstmal generell jeder von uns
und und weiß ich nicht wenn ich jetzt
was positives über mich sagen soll das
ist vielleicht dass ich nicht so
voreingenommen bin oder so und sehr
aufgeschlossen und sehr freundlich aber
dass andere menschen auch das ist jetzt
nicht einzigartig diese diese
eigenschaft und was mich selber
einzigartig gemacht ist genau das was
ihnen von uns einzigartig macht das ist
ein nur einmal gibt und zwar genau so
wie man es okay du würdest es keine
herausragende charaktereigenschaft doch
ein paar ich habe aber auch schwächen
also wie gesagt ich finde also ich lache
unheimlich gern bin
bin nicht voreingenommen sehr
aufgeschlossen und und und und
hilfsbereit und genau so bin ich aber
auch irgendwie chaotisch man kann mit
mir schlecht planen hier habt ihr schon
mal freunde enttäuscht weil ich
kurzfristig absagen musste oder so sind
halt auch also bin nicht perfekt
wer ist schon perfekt ja so mal wieder
eine rote irgendwie war die rede
die grünen sind aber die sind meine die
sind lobt aber das ist ja noch viel aber
dieses jahr nicht schön ach die sind so
habe ich jetzt noch richtig ja ja da
kommt eine ganz schlimme da habe ich
immer so wenn sie schlimm dabei sein
schlechtes gefühl
das ist aber doch okay wie bei frisch
gepresst hast du auch im echten leben
keine kinder
wer weiß sind sie für dich nur
nervensägen weil das ist in dem film am
am anfang denkt man wo kinder sind ja
die hölle ich kann es ja schwarz auf
weiß belegen dass kinder liebe ich hab
ja ein kinderbuch geschrieben die kleine
spinne widerlich stimmt ich liebe kinder
ja ja gut tolle unvoreingenommene wesen
die sich ganz frei auf die welt
einlassen und manchmal ist das freie so
so so frei wie man da sieht warum ist so
selbstbewusst dass immer so lieb gemeint
ist eure eure grünen fragen total süß
aber so schwer weil sich selber so zu
komplimente zu geben ich weiß es sich
irgendwie von unbedingt so selbstbewusst
das ist es gibt auch situationen in
denen ich das nicht so drin
also es ist aber muss es dem vogel dann
muss man muss auf jeden fall
man sollte auf jeden fall 60 frauen
irgendwie sich auch was einzulassen und
das dann einfach auch einfach noch
dahinter stehen hinter dem was man macht
oder es uns bleiben das oder zumindest
wenn du da machst auch dazu stehen
aber es gibt auch situationen wo ich
auch sehr unsicher bin okay nur
menschlich nach rote noch zum schluss
oder eine route
oder jetzt hier die böse auf die du
gewartet hast das ist jetzt die böse
aber die nehmen wer noch zum schluss
warum mit grünen augen wenn wir eine rot
da glaube ich nicht vergisst
12 absagen von schauspielschulen warum
hörst dich nicht auf wachleute
das ist sehr süß gemeint aber schaut
euch die fachleute mal an die da sitzen
also das ist ja nicht alle aber es ist
es war schon teilweise sehr böse und
zumal man muss halt überlegen dass man
wirklich ganz so anfang steht sich da
ausprobiert und ich hab dann auch den
fehler gemacht haben vielleicht nicht zu
die richtigen rollen ausgesucht habt
dann irgendwie mit meinen also viele
wieso suchst du dir in deinen jungen
jahren so eine gräfin tops oder die
ehrbare dirne frau mit so vielen männern
erfahrung du bist doch gar so nimmst du
nicht die hühner oder sogar gut hat mir
noch keiner gedacht ich nicht beim
nächsten mal die julia oder das gretchen
muss man ja auch erst mal wissen
und da ich das mir selber angeeignet es
war teilweise schon wirklich wirklich
böse also dass ich ganz ganz ganz neu
beweint happel das echt richtig traurig
gemacht hat ist es so dass da irgendwie
von oben herab wirklich über seine
zukunft mit seiner leichtigkeit
entschieden wird
und da gar nicht drüber nachgedacht wird
und das finde ich halt das echt appell
an alle dozenten
das sind leute die sich das ganze zu
herzen nehmen manchmal und das sollte
man einfach nicht so gemeint sein
und wenn es fachleute sind an seine
fachlichen tipp mit auf den weg geben
wenn wir dich jetzt so an wirklich
traurige szenen erinnert haben dann
müssen wir noch eine grüne zum abschluss
aber es wirklich das geht an die
substanz wenn man grad also weil er
seine entscheidung für dich ob du jetzt
die nächsten drei jahre dorthin ziehst
oder nicht und ist ein ganzes leben
beeinflusst absolut gut pass auf jetzt
kommt die könnte auch rot sein die frage
du kannst dir selber interpretieren ob
sie so roth oder begrünt ist ja warum
haben sie gerade dich für die verfilmung
von frisch gepresst ausgesucht ja das
ist ja eine frage die ich leider sowieso
gar nicht richtig beantworten kann weil
das ist zwar kenne ich nicht aber nicht
gesagt so ich suche mich mal aus für die
rolle seiner entscheidung von frau
zietlow ich habe mich sehr gefreut dass
es so simpel dass ich genau ich habe
mich sehr gefreut dass sie auf mich mit
dem projekt zu kommen weil ich mich als
sofort mit dem stoff identifizieren
konnte und
wir haben von anfang an also es hat
keine große überlegung gebraucht bis ich
dazu gesagt habe super dann wünsche ich
dass das noch ganz oft passiert danke
schön dann wieder batterien
es ist ein skandal
nora tschirner hat kein entweder das
erklärt sie ihn fragen unter unter
anderem und nah sagt batman ist nichts
für kinder also aufgepasst und fragen
oder gucken